bonsoir stéphane donc un direct de
londres cette première partie entre gary
kasparov et l'animé rqra nique pour
sebring game world championship a tenu
ses promesses on va dire malgré le
résultat
la première partie c'est toujours un
événement exceptionnel dans un match
puisque la première partie va en tout
cas être déterminante pour la suite du
tendre et particulièrement d'ouverture à
partir couvertures petite surprise
kasparov jouent aux quatre déjà on
s'attendait peut-être plus à des quatre
coups contre kramnik est par contre c
chronique qui le premier a surpris qu'à
ses parents oui puisque kasparov a joué
eu 4 et la cram nick a ouvert avec eux 5
comme s'il voulait jouer une défense
petrov mais sur cavalière 3 enlevés un
tout à l'heure il a dérivé pour une
espagnole variante à la mode
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut dire d'abord
c'est que le match a déroulé avec un peu
de retard il ya eu des petits projets
d'organisation on peut dire que
globalement c'est vrai que
l'organisation est pas encore totalement
rodé c'est vrai que réalisation d'un
match de championnat du monde c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
difficile et là en l'occurrence on a
affaire à des gens qui n'ont jamais
organisé de match de ce calibre en tout
cas de match d'un sport comme les échecs
et effectivement ils éprouvent quelques
difficultés de mise en route mais en
tout cas ça ça va être résolue dans les
jours à venir
alors ça m a joué dans les jours à venir
alors pour commencer d'avoir ce cette
petite émission donc on fait un petit 20
26 minutes pour essayer de résumer un
petit peu la partie mais on va voir
aussi des images du match des petits
passages amusants qu'on a essayé de
retrouver de la journée donc on a vu un
kasparov en forme notamment au niveau
des greens ans kasparov et ses fameuses
mimiques donc qui l'ont rendu célèbre
puisque kasparov c'est quand même un
véritable acteur c'est une bête de scène
kasparov il est là il fait son show il
fait son spectacle et donc nous allons
voir et bien les images qui sont là là
vladimir kramnik s'installe les deux
joueurs s'installent beaucoup de flash
inde en ce début de partie il y avait
une tonne de journalistes journal et je
pèse mes mots en pleine lumière on peut
dire qu espèrent bien éclairé en train
de doubler ses pièces les deux joueurs à
double c'est à dire remettre leurs
pièces en place derrière on voit raymond
keane qui est le cerveau de beaune games
qui a fait l'émission
le petit résumé de la journée avec dani
c'est l'anecdote synthétique de la
journée comme quoi tout est possible
garry kasparov réfléchi comme une bête
je réfléchis très cassant fait hélas le
papier qui arrive à petit comme kasparov
ne comprend pas et virent donc le papier
en dehors de son champ de travail à pied
inopportun cramique réfléchi et la
kasparov en gros signifie à son
adversaire bon bah c'est bon il ya plus
rien à faire dans cette position
maintenant tu vas me proposait nul voila
et ils ont conclu rapidement après donc
voilà ces quelques images de banyuls et
vous avez pu voir d'ailleurs que
stéphane est assis à la place de gary
kasparov
oui et que je suis à la place de
vladimir kramnik puisqu'ils n'ont pas
les mêmes fauteuil alors je peux dire
d'ailleurs que c'est effectivement pas
très confortable oui effectivement
kasparov ne veut pas jouer sur un
fauteuil confortable puisqu'il a peur de
s'endormir peur d'être moins efficace
alors que vladimir kramnik lui arbore
des pauses bien en arrière bien relax
garry kasparov lui est toujours en avant
d'ailleurs tu peux peut-être nous
montrer comment il fait
oui mais il est comme ça et comme ça
extrêmement motivés voilà extra l'on
fait on le voit bien sur les images que
vous que moi voilà on va tout de suite
venir à cette partie donc si on peut
voilà nous mettre à la partie en place
donc on va revenir dans cette partie
parce qu'on n'a pas énormément de temps
à 26 minutes pour essayer de la résumer
alors c'est une partie intéressante mais
qui reste technique quand même puisqu'il
n'y a pas eu de feu d'artifice on est
même arrivé à une blocage de blocus
c'est à dire que pendant le direct
puisqu'on fait indirects évidemment
avant chacun de ces résumés et bien on a
eu des passages de blanc puisque
kasparov réfléchi pendant une demi heure
on ne sait pas pourquoi dans une
position qui n'a l'air de rien qui ne
n'a aucune complication n'y a pas de
promesses tactique délirante
m'enfin on va y venir tout de suite en
tout cas tout ça pour vous dire qu'il ya
quand même des live avant les parties
qui sont les moments intéressants les
vraiment les moments forts c'est comme
un jeu de foot en direct là c'est le
téléfoot
on est tout à fait aux 4,5 alors petite
surprise de 4,2 caspar aux bambins qui
jouent aux 4 et des quatre années pas en
avant mais contre le tram dit que
peut-être s'attendait plus à des quatre
pions de la dame et la banque rami que
bon mais il essaie de jouer 5 alors il
est adepte kramnik de jouer lada petrov
il ya beaucoup je vous la p3 oui alors
là petrov c'est après cavaliers f3 qui
est le coût que garry kasparov joue
systématiquement dans cette position
c'est bien entendu le coût qui avait g8
f6 donc le coup symétrique
comment jouer
il ya quelques siècles de sa ont joué la
symétrie c'est toujours aussi à la mode
qu'auparavant puisque les noirs arrivent
à faire nul très facilement en jouant
auquel il ya six ans général alors
peut-être qu est-ce qu on s'attendait à
cette défense que le crâne n'est qu'à
l'habitude de jouer et avait sûrement
préparé quelque chose et là mais la
surprise vient avancé vladimir kramnik
qui joue qu'à et c6 lançant le débat sur
a priori l'espagnol ou alors l'écossaise
l'écossaise que kasparov a joué contre
karpov au match de lyon en 90 pour la
première fois c'est la première fois
qu'on utilise l écossaise dans un
championnat du monde d'échecs
c'est le coût des deux des quatre ici
qu'ils avaient une mauvaise réputation
mais qui a été remis au goût du jour par
kasparov
mais pour cette première partie gary
préfère jouer ses classiques
c'est-à-dire le coup trois fous b5
l'ouverture espagnole et la deuxième
surprise de cramique puisque donc on
s'attendait
s'il rentrait avec a laissé six à un
espagnol de jouer le coup à cette assise
ce qu'est le coût normal dans la
position n' aurait choisi ne va rien de
secondaire 2 l'espagnol cavaliers 6 tout
de suite alors secondaire attention
puisque c'est comme la vente qui est
vraiment à la mode en ce moment c'est à
dire énormément de partie avec kevin f6
tout le monde s'est mis à jouer ça c'est
une nouvelle jeunesse pour cette
ouverture qui a été abandonné il ya
assez longtemps de cela voilà donc été
secondaire aventure revenu au premier
plan
garry kasparov joue petit rock laissant
le pion aux quatre ans prises mais c'est
très thématiques dans les espagnols ou
dans ce genre de système en tout cas
d'un rappeur puisqu'on peut jouer la
tour en e1 attaqué le cavalier après que
1,5 les récupérer oui tout à fait mais
bon ici donc en tout cas ça oriente
comme une espagnole comme si les coûts à
6 x 4 avait été interpellé mais ils ne
l'ont pas été donc on joue cavalier
prendre 4 mais enfin on va pas passer
trop de temps sur l'ouverture puisque
quand même la partie commence après des
4 tout le monde connaît très bien les
joueurs ont joué très vite qu'avec des
six fours ans et 6 donc faut près de
pionnier de la dame pour libérer le flou
si vite
et ici on joue des prend 2,5 tout
simplement les blancs veulent gagner du
temps est arrivé dans une finale où ils
auront un avantage de développement et
les re le roi noir sera des rockets donc
alain cette position va c'est là où on
sait que tout de suite il va pas y avoir
de grosses attaques dans la partie
puisque les dames sont échangés c'est
souvent un signe des deux parties plus
techniques positionnelle stratégiques ou
là disons que les blancs vont donc
essayer de jouer contre les pions doublé
c7 et c6 et les noirs eux vont essayer
de profiter à long terme de l'avantagé
de la paire de fou le fou c'est 8 et le
fouet suite qu'ils peuvent faire un
malheur en finale
effectivement la paire de fou peut
toujours se réveiller ça c'est un
élément fort maintenant garry kasparov
évidemment ne donnera pas cette chance à
vladimir kramnik et jeu qu'avait laissé
trois développement des pièces très
classiques et là le fameux coup nouveau
qui a plongé kasparov dans une
méditation sans fin fu 17 fou décès
n'ont pas tout à fait nouveau c'est déjà
été jouée mais disons que par par
cramique sûrement pas par conviction pas
par un joueur de haut niveau ça n'a pas
été joué non plus c'est à mon avis des
joueurs pas trop fort qui ont joué fou
ça a l'air d'être un coup un peu étrange
et l'idée et nouvelle puisque avant on
allait systématiquement avec le roi vers
la case au mythe et la chronique affiche
son intention de partir de l'autre côté
c'est à dire vers s'est vite donc c'est
ça la véritable nouveauté de ce courroux
17 c'est l'idée de partir avec le roi un
peu à contre pied de l'autre côté alors
ça c'est intéressant parce que ça veut
dire dans le match 6 4 6 4 par of rejoue
cette ouverture ils seront confrontés à
cette préparation de travnik là
aujourd'hui on peut dire que dans la
préparation c'est kramnik qui a dominé
kasparov kremnica explosé kasparov
puisqu'il a pris simplement une heure
d'avancé dans l'ouverture la kasparov a
réfléchi une bonne demi-heure avant de
produire le coût 10 des trois courses
tout à fait naturel et alors on va quand
même faire quelques précisions sur cette
position puisqu'on a eu le temps de
pendant le direct donc de s'y attarder
oui et on a conclu que le plan des
blancs l'unique plan des blancs
possibles
ce n'est pas un jeu pièce c'est un jeu
de pions il faut essayer de mettre en
avant cette masse de pions f2 g2 c'est à
dire les quatre pions contre trois en
sont leurs cinq est relevé de h2 contre
f sept g7 et h7 ces majorités depuis un
an il faut essayer de les pousser pour
créer un pion passé et puis crée une
désorganisation chez les noirs oui
d'autant plus que le cavalier f5 n'a pas
vraiment de cases si on arrive à le
pousser avec les pions il va se
retrouver mal placé les placements vont
être encombré car les noirs n'ont pas
beaucoup d espace ça c'est très
important c'est le plan des blancs dans
cette position mais au préalable garry
kasparov décide de sortir ces pièces
c'est à dire de terminer son
développement on ne peut pas lui
reprocher sa voix la b3 il donc vu jouer
le fou sur la grande diagonale
d'ailleurs ça arrive l'admirent krainik
jouage 6 pour contrôler la case est
simple on ne sait jamais il va empêcher
le collège 3 donné en gsm dans certaines
variables certaines variantes sûrement
four b2 mais deux et maintenant le roi
va en suite à ses deux petits bouts qui
ont l'air de rien cicero s'est vite
mais bon ça fait partie de la
préparation de trani ça fait partie de
la préparation de chronique en fait les
noirs dans cette position 10o blanc
allez-y faites un peu ce que vous voulez
moi je m'en fous j'ai un plan à très
long terme c'est à dire que je vais
jouer vraisemblablement b6 roye b cette
c5 peut-être le fourneau 6 je vais
sortir mes pièces c'est vraiment sur du
long terme et il n'ya pas d'objets date
avec moi l'opposition de voir n'y a pas
de faiblesse et c'est ça qui a dû plaire
à vladimir kramnik dans cette position
puisqu'on sait de positionnement ces
problèmes en des meilleurs joueurs de la
planète en fait il attend les blancs et
si les blancs ne font rien ils vont
finir par avoir des problèmes contre la
paire de fouet ners
oui mais des problèmes quand la paire de
fou h3 donc h3 l'idée c'est de jouer g2g
4 oui sans aucun doute
g4 suivi du cavaliere 3 qui s'en va et
qui laisse le passage au deuxième pion
le pion au fcc pour mettre en branle la
majorité des pions donc b6 il veut
mettre le roi l'abri pour mettre la tour
à 8 ans je tôt ou tard et là nous avons
affaire un castor hoffman un way qui
jouent tour à des 1 voilà parce qu'ils
développent la tour et il empêche 3,17
puisque le fou 17 maintenant est en
prise de la tour voilà tout à fait ici
krainik joue cavalier set commence à
replacer son cavalier il enlève de la
case f5
il veut le ramener rassemblement sur la
casse g6 et peut-être même si c'est
possible en f4 puis en de 6 ça c'est un
plan assez classique dans ce type de
position kallos est donc là on avait
fait une belle analyse je pense pendant
la partie c'est le les casses contrôlé
par les noirs vous voyez il ya une sorte
de muraille qui a été établie les cases
rouges et blancs ne peuvent pas y
accéder
ça fait un beau barrages
voilà à noter donc pour la suite de la
partie que la caisse h5 n'est pas
contrôlée par les noirs donc salée à
l'art de rien stockage mais elle peut
faire l'objet de la du positionnement
d'un cavalier blanc qui pourrait
éventuellement faire pression sur le
pion g7 et des du fou en b2c que ça peut
jouer kasparov a vu ce défaut dans la
position noir et il s'empresse de jouer
cavalier 2 avec l'idée qu'avait dit f4
et cavaliers h5 sur quoi cramique un
conte par cavaillé g6 et l'a donc
impossible puisque sur kg 3 les noirs
jose calif 4 donc c'est l'évasion de le
carénage en cas de contrôle 1 h 5 et ce
cavalier bien placée en juin
quatre cavaliers la kasparov et un
ballet de cavaliers donc là il veut
jouer f2f quatre probablement pour
menaces et f5
oui exactement exactement il a libéré le
pion f donc c'est toujours dans son idée
c'est lié au courage 3,12 à l'heure il
veut mettre en branle sa majorité de
lyon oui oui non mais ça c'est l'idée
ses idées claires des blancs dans cette
position et le sang froid de rami qui
est quand même très très impressionnant
h5 donc la sas et s'est dirigé
directement contre le congé de g4
kramnik lutte contre les pions blancs
c'est clair c'est très curieux parce que
notre ami cas pas ses pièces au centre
ils arrivent quand même à bien se
débrouiller quoi sur les alliances il
n'a pas besoin de pièces en fait ils
jouent sans pièces non en fait le gros
avantage de la position noir c'est qu'il
ya pas de faiblesse de pions et ça c'est
très important
carspach of ne peut pas placer ses
pièces dans une configuration qui
créerait des problèmes en noir ouais
parce que le pion faible 7 mais il faut
aller chercher quoi qu'elle ait des 3c 5
g league continue sur sa lancée donc
c'est 5 c'est l'idée c'est sûrement de
mettre le fou en c6 s'appelait aussi de
contrôler la case des 4 on les savait
qu'il peut à me fâcher les blancs de
manoeuvre un cavani casque orange ou c4
assez logique
et là on ne voit pas trop ce que
chronique et envie de faire dans cette
position puisque là en fait si c'était
très bizarre parce que pendant les
commentaires on savait plus trop où
donner de la tête
oui malheureusement on se disait bon
alors les blancs on sait pas ce qu'ils
veulent faire
les noirs on sait pas non plus ce qu'ils
veulent faire non mais en tout cas
en tout cas on a du mal à comprendre
pourquoi fait on était assez mitigé
pendant la partie et ce qui se passe
c'est que cramique avait fait la
conception je pense la plus forte
ouais c'est à dire donc il a joué à cinq
coups curieux a priori c'est son premier
de valider l'idée la menace c'est de
jouer à 5 à 4 pour essayer d'ouvrir la
colonne de la torah vite mais on pensait
avant que kramnik joue le coup que la
réponse de kasparov d'ailleurs on va la
voir tout de suite à deux à quatre baies
d'être suffisante pour parer l'idée de
ce coup et odile et noir sont toujours
embêté mais en fait une petite
différence d'imposition
oui c'est que maintenant le pion b3
alors tenez vous bien ce pion qui n'a
l'air absolument pas menacé
huet emprise et ça ça change tout
puisque dans énormément de variantes le
fou 17 vient au f5 puis en c2 et attaque
et en même temps la tour et le pion b3
et gamecube et 3 et c'est la razzia
c'est la radio parce que les deux autres
pions sont faibles aussi et donc les
noirs se régale vous avez tout à fait
donc ici h4 joué par chronique dans un
premier temps il stoppe complètement la
majorité de kasparov et après qu'elle et
ses trois ils jouent faut aussi à la
fois aussi ce petit coup pour jouer le
roi en fait son problème c'est de jouer
le roi pour activer la tour donc il
fallait trouver une classe pour le fou
quelle idée 5
kasparov suit son plan oui c'est très
logique tour h5
c'est là qu'on commence à mieux
comprendre ce que chronique était en
train de faire commencer quand même à
mieux le cerner puisque la tour en 1 h 5
c c'est un très beau plan il a
neutralisé les pions de kasparov les
cuves de g 2 h 3 complètement neutralisé
la tour 11,5 alors elle est super bien
placé puisque donc le cavalier et latour
attaque le pion aux 5
c'est important et la tour peut
éventuellement venir sur la casse g5 ou
là elle attaquera le roi blanc donc
c'est quand même assez important
oui oui c'est clair l'entourage 5 à très
fort cavani de trois jouées par kasparov
et maintenant alors la menace de
kasparov s est jouée f4 et f5 là c'est
pour ça que le cas où il y revient à eux
trois ils contrôlent la cazelle 5 tout à
fait capitale les cram nico s'en fout en
fait oui pour l'instant pour l'instant
ça va parce qu'il faut jouer deux coups
et jouera bessette est en fait sur le
coup f2f 4 il y aurait le coup
kyle et g6 en hausse est fou c'est 3
plus étroite les pouces et 3 donc alors
c'est pas facile de continuer dans ces
conditions on va continuer quand même
fou ces trois joué par gary kasparov 1
tour 8 chroniques continuent à sortir
ses pièces ton des deux le coup joué par
toujours par kasparov et maintenant
effectivement les noirs n'ont plus de
nom plus trop de problème puisque de
toute façon sur f4 les noirs sont
tranquilles ils joueront toujours
cavalier g6 en recettes
nos clients ne voient plus de plan pour
kasparov
on ne sait plus trop ce qu'il veut et
et donc à ce moment-là on commençait à
se dire puisque kasparov était mal
autant il y avait beaucoup réfléchi on
commençait à se dire que peut-être que
chroniques et les jeux pour le gain avec
les noirs oui puisqu'il peut le mettre
la pression sur kasparov
il lui reste donc quelque chose comme
dix minutes pour jouer dix coups il a la
pression si cramique arrive à trouver
des chances de pression dans la position
il peut mettre kasparov en danger à
cause du temps donc c'était sa chance de
faire ça mais en fait kasparov a tout vu
et il a vu qu'en fait dans cette
position ni les blancs ni noirs ne
peuvent progresser sur un jeu précis
kasparov a tout vu comme d'habitude on
serait tenté de dire
donc la cram dick jauron assez vite
kasparov joue f4 et maintenant cavalier
ossètes contrôler la case f5
c'est très important à venir cavaliers
f5 rassemblement ici les blancs jouent
qu'avec 2 et la kasparov nous fait une
scène de grimaces oui c'est ce qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure dans les images un
petit peu donc il se met comme ça donc
puisque tu achètes de kasparov tu peux
peut-être simuler kasparov
non je ne peux pas trop parce que les
grimaces ont quand même difficile à
faire les climats sont difficiles à
faire mais en tout cas kasparov et une
mine tel qu'on est obligé de comprendre
qu'il a tout vu et que la position
commencé à l'ennuyer parce qu'il est sûr
qu'elle est nulle
on a l'impression qu'il voulait dire
akrami qu'avec ces petites riad bon on
l'a fait ce nul ou quoi là tu attends
quoi ouais c'est ça oui c'est exactement
ça c'était vraiment un bon chronique
c'est bon là cette fille là on a on
arrête on arrête on va faire du mais
j'ai pour vito proposé nul parce que
psychologiquement c'est pas bon pour lui
de proposer quelque chose
j'attendais que tu fasses je vais
attendre que tu proposes moulin
effectivement donc il joue qu'avec deux
chroniques joue cavalier f5 ne proposant
pas nul hélas kasparov énervé je
qu'avaient les points cavaliers et
propose nul voilà cinq rames nikkei a
gagné pour ainsi dire la petite guerre
psychologique autour de cette
proposition
voilà donc la position nul donc ce qu'on
peut dire conclusion de cette première
partie c'est que kramnik a réussi à
surprendre kasparov
il a dominé autant kasparov s'est quand
même bien sorti de la situation il n'a
pas craqué il sait
heureusement pour lui évidemment mais il
a bien tenu la distance il s'est pas
laissé démonter par cramique s'est pas
laissé déborder par ce parce et y
compris par la pression du temps il a
bien géré son affaire il s'en sort avec
une nulle tranquille mais quand même
petit avantage psychologique pour
kramnik puis c'est toujours mieux de
faire nul avec les noirs et surtout
quand on voit qu'il a dominé 15 kasparov
dans le choix de sa préparation
chronique elle jouait facilement cette
partie je pense que c'est une chose
qu'on peut noté il a joué très vite il a
eu aucun problème à aucun moment ses
dires même au moment où pendant le live
on était là en train de dire qu'à sport
va gagner regarder qu'à sport au filet
par tous il prend toutes les cases en
fait qu'un ami qui était très serein il
avait raison je pense qu'il a très très
bien préparé cette position et j'attends
avec impatience la partie numéro 3 alors
on attend aussi avec impatience parti
numéro 2 parce que l'on va voir ce que
kramnik a prévu avec les blancs oui on
verra scrabble thermique a prévu avec
les blancs sur itunes alors je peut se
diviser en fait en 2 min match 1 ou
casse parfait les blancs et l'autre au
crâne et corps les noirs 2 min match
celui partie du temps alors par contre
si la chronique arrive à surprendre
kasparov avec les blancs ça risque de
faire mal
il faut dire au niveau des statistiques
puisque ça peut jouer kasparov n'a
jamais battu cramique avec les pièces
noires en revanche grammy qui a déjà
battu kasparov quand il conduisait les
en syrie ils ont trois gains chacun
kasparov a gagné trois fois avec les
blancs les chroniques a gagné deux fois
et et blanc et une fois avec les noirs
voilà pour ce qui est des statistiques
donc autant de rendez-vous à mardi pour
un nouveau direct à partir de 15h heure
anglaise et 16h heure française
et puis le soir conférence de presse
suivie donc de nos deux émissions en
direct
et voilà diagonale c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui merci d'avoir suivi ce
spécial londres